all right we are now live for another
political theory and practice discussion
i try to do these monthly but sometimes
i get a little bit bogged down
this is the end of the semester and it's
a great day because it's very gloomy
here
nobody's going anywhere
for discussing some things that have to
do with
local state and national politics and
the practice that we're looking at
and some of the
theorization around it is called
either gary mandering or gerrymandering
you can say it either way
it's actually named after an american
politician from massachusetts whose name
was gary
and he created these legislative
districts that one of them looked like a
salamander so that's where the
gerrymander thing originally came from
but you see it happening in other places
as well
i'm going to talk mostly about the
american context and about
in particular my state of wisconsin
this is a you know significantly
problematic
uh political practice that i think is
undermining
not just democracy but also
accountability
and um you know leading to greater
factionalization
and and i think it dismays a lot of
people and actually i'm gonna i'm gonna
hit on um something that that tom
mcdowell is saying here and problematize
that a little bit he says this should be
an interesting discussion the principal
question it seems to me is whether the
majority principal
to serve as the foundation of our
political institutions
and that is part of it but that is not
the single main thing there's a lot of
different aspects to this gerrymandering
is bad
not just because it ends up violating
say majority rule
but also for other reasons as well that
we want to attend to so
let's let's talk first what is
gerrymandering right so if you want to
define it and there's different
definitions of it out there
it is a
deliberate practice so it's not
something that just happened to come
into being it's it's something that's
deliberately done by somebody
of creating
maps that are non-representative
for the purposes of political
representation and when you frame it
like that
you can see that there's going to be a
problem with it a contradiction right
the purpose of creating these political
maps of districting is is what it's
often called
is um
it's supposed to to allow for
some sort of political exchange some
some representation of different
interests and there's there's a lot of
different ways you could theorize this
you could talk in terms of you know
majority rule and one person one vote
and we'll we'll get to that in a bit but
you might also think about the need for
different interests to be adequately
represented in the political process
because when we vote
we don't do direct democracy really
anywhere i mean we have referendums
occasionally there are swiss cantons
that do things like that but for the
most part we're dealing with
representative democracy and that means
that we put people into office and then
we hope that they're going to represent
us represent our interests and that you
know if we think about this in an
aristotelian sense that somebody
representing district 1 is not just
going to represent the people from their
party in district 1 or their donors in
district one but the totality of the
people
involved there right so the problem with
gerrymandering is that it
it undermines that and deliberately does
so for
other
values other purposes which which wind
up being
not only to the detriment of many people
but
primarily oriented towards the interest
of
a select few and it could be
you know a money delete it could be
a political party it could be an ethnic
group there's a lot of different ways in
which this can
happen
i kind of suspect although i don't this
is not something i've researched that
this has been going on for a long time
and as i was thinking about it today i i
thought that maybe somebody might bring
up the um problem in you know great
britain of rotten burrows and and that's
not quite the same thing as
gerrymandering gerrymandering you're
trying to associate
people into districts and the districts
should be about the same population size
although they won't be the same map size
rotten burrows was people being elected
as you know uh representatives from
places that didn't have any population
and we are going to see
one example that's kind of like that
with
prisoners here in the united states one
thing i do want to remind everybody
especially those who are not from you
know the united states and are tuning in
from all over the world
the united states is a complicated
political
patchwork we have a federal government
right and federal government has its
three branches as everybody learns in
civics class the executive the
legislative and the judicial and then
each state
has its own thing that it's doing
and each state is independent of the
other states so each state is sending
its own representatives to the federal
government
and it's also got its own stuff
happening its own you know house and
senate or whatever they happen to call
it in each state and each state has its
own maps for these sorts of things
it even affects um
counties and cities we are having a
major redistricting fight here in
wisconsin the state that i'm from but
we're also having a significant
redistricting fight in milwaukee county
where i live right um and and this can
happen at all the way down to the local
level um so that's something to keep in
mind you know changing something at a
federal level
might not change something at a state
level right and there's a lot of
problems with our processes here in the
united states that i'll talk about a
little bit later
so i wanted to use wisconsin as an
example to kind of drive this home to
give you something you can think about
so
if if you're not familiar with the state
of wisconsin it's kind of shaped like a
hand right with green bay being up here
the city of milwaukee where i'm living
down here madison the state capitol over
here then there's all sorts of you know
places and spaces throughout the state
and the majority of the population is
concentrated in three areas
the
milwaukee uh
you could say the four-county area
around milwaukee where i would say
probably if you if you did the
demographics at least two-fifths of the
population lives in those four counties
then there's what we call the fox cities
from green bay all the way down to
sheboygan running through all these
things in the fox river and then there's
madison dodge county where the state
capitol the largest university is and
then there's all these other places
across the state
and so the question is well how do you
draw legislative maps and
what should the proportions be
so in 2010
the republicans
had a legislative majority and they also
had our former
uh governor scott walker who is a
republican really an embarrassment to
the state he was dropped out of
marquette just down the road over there
he tried to run for president got his
ass handed to him
and still hanging around here engaging
in some some republican
culture war politics in any case they
controlled the executive and they
control the legislative which meant that
they the legislation the legislators
pass the maps here in wisconsin and then
it goes to the governor and the governor
can veto it but if the
um if the governor really likes the maps
well he's not going to and that's what
they did and so we have some very very
unrepresentative maps you know wisconsin
is what we call a purple state right
meaning that
votes are split between republican and
democrat candidates and the parties we
also have a very large uh section of
independence which includes myself i
don't belong to either party or a third
party i'm actually registered as an
independent so what's cool about that is
when it comes to primaries i can vote in
whatever primary i want to
here in wisconsin
and so you would expect that we have
eight representatives that go to the
house of representatives
and that it would be evenly split but
it's not because of the way the maps are
drawn
we also at the state level the
republicans even though they
they actually get less votes
they have a super majority they control
61 out of 99
seats in the state assembly so you can
tell that some gerrymandering is going
on very deep is asking what is
gerrymandering we talked about that a
little bit earlier so let me just remind
everybody it's a practice of creating
non-representative maps in order to
accomplish certain political
aims for for districting and we'll talk
about it more but anybody else who pops
in you should probably google it right
so so that you you know what we're we're
talking about or read the description
that we have
in the the video back to the state
assembly so that means that the
republicans
even though they got less than half of
the vote they have more
well more than half of the state
assembly representatives and when it
comes to the senate it's even worse 21
out of 33
senate seats in the wisconsin senate are
republican even though they did not
you know they did
you could say they didn't deserve in
just in terms of sheer votes to win
those right
so that's that's a significant problem
wisconsin is probably more
gerrymandered at this point in time than
any other state but a lot of other
states are really working on it north
carolina
terrible problem there texas big problem
there it also works sometimes to the
favor of the democrats
illinois just to the south of us is a
democrat controlled state and they do
gerrymandering to you know basically
ensure democratic power um and so you
know it works both ways it's not it's
not just the republicans doing it
although the republicans are much more
egregiously doing it at this point and
in purple states that is states that
could go either way as opposed to a blue
state like like illinois or a red state
like you know idaho or something like
that it's the republicans who are really
playing fast and loose and being hyper
partisan when it comes to this
and
you know some of these cases have gone
to the supreme court and the supreme
court is dominated by republicans so the
supreme court uh with some of these
cases said now we're not even going to
hear it
and in other cases said oh it's just
fine you know so we're not getting a lot
of judicial relief
as the american people from from these
sorts of problems
so
that's a little bit of a background
let's let's talk about
why it takes place why why would you
want to engage in gerrymandering and
this this shows you how complicated the
issue is
um sometimes it's bipartisan
and so this actually goes to uh some of
the questions that are being asked uh
like mario says doesn't it suck to have
only two parties it totally sucks to
have only two parties we don't actually
only have two parties we have all sorts
of third parties
but the two parties totally dominate the
political process they're the only ones
that are getting tons and tons of money
from from corporations and uh pacs and
other interests you know uh
organizations like the nra or uh you
know the american association of retired
people or these these massively
influential
blocks that that have a lock on the
lobbying process
so
back to bipartisan so the republicans
and democrats could get together
and say
we're going to work together so that
some of the seats are like solid
republican and those can be safe seats
for our candidates
and
then the democrats would say okay we'll
we'll have some of our seats safe for us
and
then you know then they have to divvy up
the other ones now who gets who gets
left out everybody else right so if
you're in the
green party or the constitution party or
the libertarian party
um you're screwed you're not part of
that process any more than you get to
participate in the presidential debates
you know there they always have to have
like their own little debate for third
parties right i'm getting a lot of uh
uh
questions and comments here which i'll
try to get to a little bit later on
um
so bipartisan uh gerrymandering that's
that's been going on for a long time and
there are some bad effects to that
the creation of safe seats we're going
to get to that in a bit i think that
that's that's a significant problem
then there can be deliberately partisan
gerrymandering like what is happening
here in wisconsin and what happened here
10 years ago
what goes on in north carolina what goes
on on the democrats uh
favor in illinois
and that's where a party that has like a
super majority for a little while
uses that power
to consolidate their control over the
the electoral and legislative process
and that is what is going on here in in
wisconsin it's like a never-ending grind
when tony evers our new governor was
elected
the
the republican-dominated legislature
moved immediately to try to strip as
many powers from him as they could they
were cool with having their guy scott
walker the republican and letting him do
whatever he wanted but when a democrat
gets in they they try to undermine them
um
so that's you know that's partisan
gerrymandering um
there can be other things that that are
done racial gerrymandering it was a
significant issue here in the united
states
it's officially ruled out by the voting
rights act it's prohibited but you know
does that really
um prevent it from happening not not
really i mean
uh there there's a tendency especially
when it
like a state like ours
it mostly tends to be trying to dilute
the native american vote as much as
possible among the sea of whiteness
and to try to aggregate the
uh
african-american and
hispanic vote as much as possible into
just a few districts this was called
packing we're going to talk about that
in a bit and you know there's there's
some benefits to that i mean it does
ensure that you are going to get some
minority representatives in so there is
you know
there's probably a good side to it in
terms of um
the legislative process and decision
making
but it also tends to
in effect
make a lot of people's votes not count
and in other countries this might be on
the basis of religion or
ethnicity or linguistic lines right that
often happens
as well
um so we've got three kinds now
bipartisan partisan and racial slash
ethnic slash religious gerrymandering
here in the united states it's primarily
racial
and you can also have another kind of
gerrymandering that's
i think kind of unique to us here in the
united states maybe somebody else knows
of examples elsewhere
so as many of you probably know if you
have committed a felony in the united
states and this goes by state by state
you may lose your voting rights
and you might lose them permanently or
you might lose them for a certain amount
of time you probably don't have them
while you're in prison a few states that
are that are you know very enlightened
do allow that but most states don't
so
there's this redistricting thing that
goes with taking prisons that might have
a population anywhere from you know 200
to 2000
and counting those
as
citizens within that district
and
not letting them vote
which violates the one-person one-vote
you know
principle uh and this is this is a big
problem here in the united states i
would say that you have a similar kind
of thing
when it comes to universities where
where do the the students actually
count as um living you know it it
sometimes they're aggregated into places
but this you know and say the prisons is
much bigger is much bigger problem
because obviously it's very difficult
for them to vote even even if they're
allowed to whereas students you know
sometimes um well it's the republicans
mostly who will like try to make sure
that there's no voting on campus or
there's no voting places near campus but
that you can overcome you just you know
the students can find ways to get to the
polling spaces right
so these are the different kinds of
gerrymandering that are that are taking
place
um
there could be other sorts that that
come up but those are the main types and
then here's the question what are the
effects okay so if we go all the way
back up to the top tom mcdowell talks
about the majority principle ought to
serve as the foundation of our political
institutions so gerrymandering is a
violation of that what is the majority
principle well the majority
should get to
you know decide who actually gets
elected or what the
uh
you know the course of actions are going
to be or if there's a mandate who has
the mandate
so
when you have gerrymandering going on
that's violated and this is a this is a
big problem um you know if we want to
claim that we actually live in a
democracy which is very debatable um
some states like wisconsin are clearly
not a democracy at this point because of
what the republican party has been doing
um you know actually they're trying to
get the wisconsin election commission
thrown in jail because they don't like
the the answers that they're getting
from there there's a lot of crazy stuff
going on here if you follow the news
in wisconsin
um
so there's this problem right it's it's
very uh bad for
representative government and i
mentioned creating um
safe seats you can also think of it as
creating
entire states where the fix is in where
your vote really doesn't count
um
it can't count because of where you live
unfortunately
and that sucks you know
i think that's very demoralizing for
ordinary people and i think that's very
demoralizing for the younger generations
who
you know are told this oh your vote
really matters every vote counts and we
find that it doesn't you know when when
we allow these sorts of practices
it's not surprising that um not
everybody votes and that a lot of people
feel like voting doesn't make a
difference because in many places it
doesn't make a difference you know
i know here in wisconsin uh in the part
that i live in if i were to vote
for a republican for my state
representative
it's not going to matter i live in a
highly democratic uh area
and um you know gwen moore will be our
representative and that's that's life
you know um i'm okay with that myself
but
you know i i kind of think it's it's
better when everybody's vote does matter
in some way
there's also this factor of protecting
incumbents safe seats
mean that
unless you really really gets you know
really screw things up like they find
child porn on your computer
or
you
say something horrible although these
days i mean
if you're a democrat and you say
something horrible if you're an
establishment democrat they'll find some
justification for you and if you're a
republican they'll actually like turn
you into t-shirts and memes and think
that you're doing great stuff and put
you on fox news and oan
so it's it's pretty difficult if you
have a safe seat to lose that safe seat
that is a significant problem right
um
and again i think that's also something
that demoralizes people people
it makes it impossible to demand
any sort of accountability from your
representatives because they don't they
don't have to care about your vote right
they know that there's a 95 percent
chance they're getting elected the next
time around right
so
this this really does undermine some of
the key ideas and principles
for having a
a what we you know call a representative
democracy or a liberal democracy this
this type of regime that most of us have
grown up in and you know we're taught in
our classes that you know this is the
ideal
um the other thing that i'll say that is
really problematic about it is it's
essentially a way of allowing elites
and partisans
and those who have the money
to capture and consolidate political
power and to make it look as if it's
fair and representative when it when it
really isn't and
so you know here in wisconsin like i've
pointed out it was the republicans who
engaged in gerrymandering creating some
really bad maps in
2011. which then have been going for a
while and that that consolidated their
power the wisconsin supreme court is is
dominated by republicans the u.s supreme
court is dominated by republicans at
this point in time so it's not like
you're going to get any help from them
because they're cool with it
and
you know
when you think about the the mindset
behind this
it feeds into a much larger problem that
we've talked about in the past about
political factionalization
the republican party has effectively
decided that they will win by any means
necessary and they will cheat and accuse
their opponents of cheating and they
will use legislative redistricting as
part of that and appeals to to the court
you know um and what that does in effect
is it it's it tells you a message they
are working only for their base so from
an aristotelian perspective they any
regime that they have is a corrupt
regime
um it's it's you know is it democratic
yeah i mean formally but it's more
oligarchical than anything else
and this is a fundamental
problem of of political character you
know when you have an entire party
that has decided
this sort of thing is okay
with you know with a few
um
outliers who then get kicked out of the
party look at you know liz cheney uh as
an example
it's it's you know that's really
problematic you don't you don't really
have a two-party system anymore you have
a party that's that's you know all about
winning by all by any means necessary
not to say there aren't some machine
democrats that are like that i mean if
you want to see some really corrupt
democratic stuff look at illinois you
know
um
and you'll see the same sort of hardball
tactics but
it's really problematic and this goes to
back to a question that somebody brought
up before the two-party system right
gerrymandering and this this
hyperpartisan politics is bad for those
of us who aren't
democrats or republicans those of us who
are independents or belong to a third
party
it's also bad for those who basically
get taken along for the ride you know if
you think about ethnic minorities and
the democrats um
uh using them essentially to to have a
voting block or you think about
um
you know
some of the people the republican party
has been able to capture who are clearly
voting against their economic interests
by voting for the republicans who are
you know like
cool with you know cutting them loose
economically
screw health care screw this screw that
just to own the libs
um
gerrymandering is part of a larger
problem
and it's a way of
it's a way of consolidating and
protecting
those those elites that are that are
running these these parties so
all right so that's that's enough
talking about gerrymandering let me
start looking at some of these
uh questions and comments damn it says
when my american friends explained
gerrymandering to me it just felt insane
how it was legal yeah and it that is a
good way to frame it you look at it and
you're like
what the hell is this [ __ ] and how
is it allowed to go on and you could say
similar things about
the american lobbying system that we
have
you know there's so many things in our
politics that are clearly dysfunctional
and clearly only work to the benefit of
those who know how to manipulate them
and if you want to get involved in party
politics because you're going to be a
reformer
you inevitably have to make so many
compromises and and you know by the time
that you get up to having any real power
to change things
you probably aren't that interested in
changing them in any significant ways so
that's a real real problem zeitgeist
says what would be the ideal setup for
district lines there is no ideal setup
it there's just like less bad and and
better
um you know ideally you want to have
so for example here in wisconsin
you know it says that that the
redistricting in the state constitution
is supposed to go along like county and
city
lines it's not supposed to be all this
weird you know windy around sort of crap
um ideally you'd have districts that are
fairly
you know almost like circular you know
they it or or they're
squares or something like that they're
not all they're not these weird things
that go off in all sorts of directions
and include you know
a bit over here and a bit over here you
know
and it's possible to do that with with
software there are some places
where a non-partisan redistricting
committee
handles that kind of stuff and you know
things can go better
unfortunately here in wisconsin it's up
to the state legislature so you know the
same corrupt people who benefited from
gerrymandering are are continuing the
gerrymandering right
uh big ball and is there really any way
to do it in a fair and balanced way
where it's not [ __ ] up either party
yeah depending on what you mean is fair
and balanced and how how you know how
much you want to emphasize the really we
don't live in a la la land of ideals we
live in a you know more or less
and i like aristotle says uh everything
in human affairs is about the more and
the less it's not about some sort of
perfect ideal
we could certainly have less
gerrymandered maps we could certainly
have things that are more representative
and i think there's a you know
we really ought to both politically and
morally so
uh tom says why do you think despite
being reasonably split between partisan
allegiances wisconsin has become
something of a
harbinger for a variety of extremist
neoliberal and anti-democratic policies
i mean i throw out the word neoliberal
because that doesn't mean anything any
to any uh it means something to some
people but it's not a helpful descriptor
let's just say like you know
pro-corporatist um you know elites
getting as much as they possibly can out
of stuff
um well it's because of scott walker and
it's because of
the you know
shift in in culture war that was going
on you know if you look at uh governor
tommy thompson he wasn't great but he
was somebody who was not hyper partisan
he was a republican governor and he he
presided over the you know the creation
of the prison complex that we have here
in wisconsin which is way way too big
right um he sucked away money from
education and into prisons but walker
was the one who was like i'm gonna break
unions and and you know um
he uh he was his partisan as he could
possibly be
and you know if you think about it you
look at the two people um thompson was
an old school republican
walker is basically a you know a grifter
a republican operative and he's
representative of what the republicans
look like here in wisconsin now
you know his uh former lieutenant
governor who's uh
husband i actually went to school with
uh rebecca clayfish is a nut job you
know but she's very popular among the
nut jobs
and there's enough of them out there
i would say that the there's also a
whole history of like
you know treating milwaukee which is
really the the major engine
for economics here as if it's something
just to exploit and that's tied in with
racism on the part of the the
republicans uh in the state so you know
wisconsin
wisconsin used to be a very progressive
state by the way i mean part of the the
legacy of that is that we have like for
our size we have four times the green
space that chicago does in part because
you know we are settled by all those uh
germans uh fleeing the failed revolution
coming coming here all across wisconsin
and bringing these ideas like poor
people should have access to parks
radical ideas like that with them but
we've really gone away from that
unfortunately and there's there's such a
mean-spiritedness
to with to wisconsin republicanism over
the last
30 years you know i grew up out in
waukesha county which is considered the
republican capital of the state
and i've seen this change i've seen
people who
at one time were decent people become
rabid ideologues and the culvert thing
has exacerbated it because unfortunately
whether you get a mask on or whether you
get inoculations became part of the
partisan split
all right um
sena how is it possible to feel
represented by only two parties is the
thing i don't understand it's super easy
if you belong to one of the two parties
isn't it
there's not much to understanding that
uh unfortunately those are those are
what we've got and both parties are
coalition parties so if you think about
you know the republican party who does
it consistent some of it is bible
bangers and some of it is you know
libertarians who say that they're you
know libertarians but they're actually
going to vote republican part of it is
people who are kind of cultural
conservatives but are not particularly
religious these are coalitions and the
republican part or the democrat party is
likewise a coalition and if you fit into
that coalition you are being represented
i mean if you don't fit into that like
myself
okay it's hard to find anybody who
represents you but it's not vital that
you feel represented um it all that's
vital is that you can vote for somebody
who can actually advance your your
interests and
sometimes you can and sometimes you
can't you know
um
so i'm not not sure how to pronounce
this with the the different letter
things
uh
cagry
celic perhaps we also have lots of party
unfortunately one dominates the whole
country yeah you can you can have uh
parliamentary systems with multi-parties
but one party could be the dominant one
you know like airdragon and turkey or
you know i think about modi uh in in
india right the bjp why did the bjp come
to power in part because of another
party dominating things the congress
party which became very corrupt and
problematic and then you replace it with
another corrupt problematic party of a
different different sort
um
zeitgeist this is a result of
politicians having a say in how district
lines are drawn yeah
so again
every state has its own process for this
in some of them like wisconsin
the politicians who are current
politicians do in fact
get to draw the lines in other states
um you might have to have a
non-partisan redistricting
group but that can be subverted as well
because like you know in recent years to
those
non-supposedly non-partisan committees
republicans have just been you know
putting operatives on there while the
democrats would get academics
so
if you have one side that is totally
unwilling to
countenance the existence of another
side
you're not going to have an easy time
with that
all right very deep says i think i got
the gist of it democracy is easily
manipulated republicans abuse it by
gerrymandering and closing polling sites
uh democrats abuse it by replacing the
voting population and control media if
you think that the democrats control the
media you're you're high
the media has its own force and a large
part of the media is actually controlled
by the republicans you know fox fox news
actually is a you know stronger uh
platform than cnn is
so let's try to avoid both scientism
here that's kind of kind of silly dan
the man i experienced that in alabama
yeah i vote but it doesn't feel like it
matters
i experienced that when i was in uh
new york you know new york was the first
place that i lived where they didn't
have open primaries you know primaries
are where we get to decide who
among the slate of candidates who is
actually going to be like the the
republican candidate or the democrat
candidate the libertarian or the green
or whatever we've got
and like here in wisconsin in illinois
where i lived in indiana it was open
primaries you know you could you could
vote in whichever one you wanted new
york
you have to like declare for a party to
to vote in their primary so i declared
republican when i was in new york
because i knew like the democrat thing
it would always be whoever the machine
democrats down in new york city decided
so it wasn't worth bothering with so i
would i would vote in the republican
primary even though i'm not really a
republican
um yeah i mean it's really quite
demoralizing isn't it to know that
your vote i mean already when you vote
in a in a massive democracy
it's really easy to feel as if your vote
doesn't matter because it's just one
person's vote right
but then when you know that the fix is
in alabama in the presidential election
it's probably never going to go
uh
democrat in our lifetime you know um and
same thing in legislative you know state
uh
elections it's it's very difficult just
like in you know if you're in california
almost none of the seats in the
california
redistricting are actually competitive
seats that sucks you know
um mario says would it be ethical to
multiply each vote depending on a score
and a test where you need to prove your
educational level in politics so you're
talking about epistocracy there have
been many proposals for that
um
it's totally unworkable jon stewart mill
by the way had a similar idea in his
remarks on representative government
um
you're never going to get people to
agree on
the test
because
you know who's going to who's going to
develop it who's going to administer it
that would already be a hyper-partisan
issue right
so
that's kind of a it's a really great
idea but it's a total non-starter
um
all right it just skipped a little bit
let me uh scroll back up
uh
yeah so here's here's another good point
that tom is pointing out and this is a
larger issue
the problem is democracies require the
observation of norms when one party no
longer adheres to them in a competitive
adversarial system it's hard to imagine
it can work
yeah we have had an erosion of norms
taking place
for
several decades and right now it's it's
much more the republicans that are that
are you know playing hardball i mean in
the early 2000s i think you could say it
was the democrats
i observed things going on and i'd be
like oh that's a bad idea to do that
because when you democrats lose power
the republicans now are going to do the
same thing
and you're not going to be able to say
oh we shouldn't do this right because
you did it yourself
and we we are at the point where it's
clear that republicans people who
identify as republicans
um
they don't think that we're in a
two-party system anymore they they think
that you know
they should take power by any means they
can
and consolidate it and fairness and all
that sort of stuff that's just window
dressing for what they want to do and it
turns out that a lot of our democratic
norms were like on the honors system um
and so we're kind of we're kind of
screwed and you know you could say well
what about the supreme court well the
supreme court only works
really well when it's a balanced
institution and it's not you know and
the supreme court doesn't always hear
cases they can pass on stuff believe it
or not
um
all right
ben says how do you feel firstly about a
two-party system where they try hard to
make a country ungovernable for the
other side
rather than cooperate and make
compromises well i think i've kind of
said how i feel about that it's
it's inherently anti-democratic from a
moral perspective it's evil i'm a virtue
ethicist you know
and um that's part of why i vote
anti-republican every election i can
because they are clearly vicious as
vicious as you can get at this point in
time which is not to you know give the
democrats a blank card or anything like
that but we are we are in a real
fix and i don't see the people who have
steered the republican party
uh and are voting for it now coming back
from that brink
you know
uh i think all the come to jesus moments
where people who were voting republican
like i have in in elections you know
and then said holy crap these people are
nuts they're they're some of them are
actively evil
and then they left um that's all
happened if somebody is is identified
with that party at this point in time
there isn't any there isn't going to be
any you know like reforming it or fixing
it so
how do i feel about that it's uh really
dismaying um
mario says corruption is to some extent
intrinsically human nature not saying
corruption can't be solved but yeah i
mean who cares i mean
it's not a question of whether it's
rooted in human nature or not i don't
think anybody uh except for extreme
idealists debates that uh it's a
question of how much corruption we're
going to allow and what we're going to
do about it right so
you know
um
straticat says just enjoy your life
what's left of it there's no way out of
this like at any time in history
so the quietest route in other words or
the consumerist route
lots of humans will be replaced by ai um
yeah i guess i mean that's certainly a
possibility
if you think that politics is actually
still worth engaging in obviously you
can't take that route but i i can
understand why a lot of young people are
like
if things are so screwed what's the
point you know
uh
donkey says uh the pendulum swim swings
back and forth might the latest
technological kicks just get us the two
to the next inflection point no i don't
think so i mean
these are the the situations that we are
facing the fundamental existential
crises
facing the human race require
unfortunately political solutions and if
we can't get our act together
then uh we lose the environment or
ai does become this dystopia or pick
whatever you want there's nothing that
says that there's a pendulum that
actually swings back and forth that's
just a nice little idea that that
doesn't actually
you know
it doesn't have any any basis in in
reality when it comes to these sorts of
things i mean i hope that we can figure
out what to do so that you know it's
clear that that global climate change is
taking place fortunately here in
wisconsin we're actually going to have
longer growing seasons and it's not
going to mess up our environment that
much but boy for the rest of the world
they're really going to be screwed and
i kind of hope that the human race does
manage to uh survive
and uh we we get something together but
the prospects are not good for
you know when we've got the the
still one of the most powerful countries
in the earth that's politically
gridlocked because of all the things
that are going on
um
dan the man how do you deal with people
that are bad faith on this issue most
republicans would recognize it's wrong
but support it to own the libs
yeah you just say that they're operating
in bad faith and you can call them evil
people because that is evil to engage in
that it's it's destructive to our
society and it's like you know actively
screwing over lots of people i mean
calling a spay to spate is very
important i think
um not that we want to like turn into
you know oh i'm just going to become a
social critic or something like that but
just being very brutally realistic and
you know frankly i don't i don't have a
lot of republican friends at this point
because uh they're all whack jobs you
know we we had our conversations about
this sort of thing and i've
either they cut me loose or i cut them
loose and you know good riddance to them
frankly
um because
i'm not gonna you know talk them out of
it
um
and that's that's the problem with with
bad faith you know
uh
zach says am i a fan of alexis de
tocqueville i am but i don't know that
the tocqueville
provides us with much of a model for
things these days i was just talking
about this with a friend that um
you know
the tocqueville really outlined some
things that were good about american
society and things that were very bad by
the way de tocqueville was one of the
people who said america for all of its
greatness has horribly mistreated and he
talked in terms of the black race and
the red race and if they don't get their
act together on this they're gonna
they're gonna screw things up and
they're gonna lose you know lose out on
on
the great things about their their place
um de tocqueville could see that writing
on the wall way back in the 1840s
um
[Music]
yeah i'm a fan but you know it's it's
it's not like you can just um
create the tocquevillian communities uh
it takes a lot of work and a lot of luck
and unfortunately
the tocqueville more often gets used by
people who are unimaginative
conservatives that he does by
by progressives so
all right um
i just skipped again let's see where we
are
um
[Music]
ethan says am i confident ron johnson
will lose election i have a sour taste
in the amount in my mouth after the
democrat lost virginia governor's race
i'm not confident i mean the republicans
are going to engage in as much voter
suppression as they possibly can and
they're you know like i said there's a
lot of
republican voters that are deliberately
stupid
and are voting for people that clearly
are not motivated to
help them and their interests you know
there's this kind of
masochistic
uh
mindset on the part of a lot of
republicans so long as they can like
hate black people and hate the libs and
you know complain about critical race
theory and and you know uh transgender
rights whatever silly nonsense they they
want and you know run down milwaukee
they're cool with with the republicans
like screwing them over at every
opportunity those are the people who
vote for ron johnson
you know
and people who who you know like to
screw other people over right
so a lot of it depends too on who the
opposition candidate is so for those who
don't know ron johnson is our one of our
current senators an absolute idiot of a
person i mean he's the guy who just just
recently he's in the news i mean he's
always in the news for saying something
stupid or for being in the pocket of the
russians
he just said recently and listerina
actually had to release a statement
about this that gargling with listerine
will prevent covet and listerine was
like
no no mouthwash doesn't prevent covet
don't listen to this idiot over here
so
you know we have a lot of people who are
willing to vote for idiots don't we so
that's kind of a problem
uh russell treadway the media tilts to
the left i think it's pretty obvious
it's stupid to deny it
well russell you're stupid yourself i
will say
because you clearly can't understand
your own biases
read across the media do a little bit of
analysis
and try to overcome your own you know
filters there's a wide spectrum of media
if you think that the media in general
tilts to the left then you probably
haven't done your work
so there's there's various media of
various sorts but the mainstream media
is not tilting left
so you're you know you probably you know
you have an opportunity here to do a
little rethinking
um
kolomoo says i think we should draw
district lines based on lottery not a
bad idea you know some sort of
randomization
process is often what is being uh
proposed by the the people who want
fairness
whether you can get that through the
processes that's a whole different
animal isn't it
nunya says a quote from gorvy dolls the
best man comes to mind
when talking dirty politics i'm kind of
a fan of vidal
he's very he's brutally realistic power
is not a toy that we give to good
children it's a weapon and the strong
man takes it and he uses it and you know
that that is quite often the case um is
that always the case do we want to
generalize that into how things always
are you know
so casual philosophy is a good point
here the media is a bit of a rorschach
test left sees it is right right sees it
as left also which media legacy
companies social media hollywood etc
yeah you have to be a lot more
considerate and nuanced about this and
actually look at what's what's going on
right
um
auntie says uh do you think instant
runoff voting can solve a lot of these
issues that we have with democracy
no i don't think instant runoff voting
can in part because you're never going
to see it
part of the problem that we've been
talking about here
is the fact that you can propose
whatever solutions you like
you have to get those solutions through
the legislative process
and get them accepted and the very
people that you're trying to
you know push out of their safe seats
are the ones who have an interest in
making sure that this never happens you
know so
all right uh
hypatia raises a really interesting
question
i wonder how the how the republicans
became so evil my feeling is it all
changed since the 2008 recession
uh yes and no i mean i look at people
who who i used to read or listen to
and they say horrible horrible things
these days and i'm like
were they always that bad and i just
didn't see it was there something wrong
with me or did they change over time you
know prime example is dennis prager you
know the the prager university is just
like garbage right and you know it just
looking at at its graphics and stuff
like that and who they have in there
dennis prager 20 years ago was a radio
host who
was worth listening to because he'd
actually listen to both sides of stuff
and he he had his point of view and he
would try to engage in like you know
careful civil argument with other people
who he disagreed with somehow he turned
into a
rabid ideologue and i don't know where
it happened i think the 2008
meltdown probably played a role in that
but
i you know i think there's other things
along the way you know having a guy like
scott walker here in wisconsin
uh in charge of things
you know um that that played a role as
well i i don't think that there's like
one single turning point or or factor
right
so
all right um
let's see
made of clay says what if they don't
think it's evil what if they think it's
the hard decision to make and therefore
makes me strong or necessary evil
lots of republicans fetishized doing the
wrong yeah that's another kind of evil i
mean you can be evil without realizing
that you're evil because there's many
kinds of evil and there's like the you
know comic book villain oh i can't wait
to [ __ ] people over and and you know
there are some republicans definitely
like that the guy you know i mentioned
joel clayfish the guy i went to school
with and rebecca clayfish
i think they are that sort of evil quite
frankly
but there's plenty that uh buy into
things that they have no business buying
into and they could they never engage in
the self-reflection required to figure
out you know sort of like that meme
right are we the baddies
um if that occurs to you
you probably should look into it and and
if you don't and you instead like turn
fox news back on
well it's kind of on you you know um
all right zeitgeist says the only way i
feel like my vote could matter is if i
voted collectively with a bunch of other
people like making an online group yeah
and that's that's the way politics in a
representative democracy is supposed to
work we're supposed to have
coalitions and caucuses and we're
supposed to associate with each other
people forget that the first amendment
isn't just about you know freedom of
religion or freedom of the press it's
also about freedom of association you
know being able to talk with other
people and say hey uh maybe maybe we
should you know
bring the taxes back up to where they
were so we can actually pay for things
that would you know result in less
people being destitute or sick or maybe
we shouldn't let the corporations do
whatever they want you know and give
them these massive tax breaks and
freedom from things or maybe we
shouldn't have qualified immunity for
for cops that use it you know in all
sorts of uh quite frankly evil ways
knowing that they're going to get away
with things maybe we should grow be able
to associate and gerrymandering prevents
that sort of thing from happening
because i could be like my neighbor
could be in a different district than me
you know
so that that's an issue
um
zeitgeist also says the only way i feel
like young people in general would gain
confidence in voting is if they were be
part of a little voting party and there
is something like that going on some of
the time
um donkey would you speak to the term
evil from a non-religious perspective as
a poly atheist i love to use that term
but it's so devilish that's just silly i
mean
people were using the word evil long
before monotheistic religion came on the
scene just read plato or aristotle you
know
you can use
you can use the word evil without it
having devilish or religious
connotations
it's part of the human condition that
people do evil to other people and some
people are in fact evil and there's a
variety of ways to to be evil so that to
me that's
i know that that some people want to say
oh evil that's you you have a religious
mindset if you use that term
historically that's just [ __ ] so
you know
all right um
ricky says i wonder what people would
think if we had the political system
rhode island wrote about in starship
troopers so the political system that
ricky is mentioning is if you don't
serve in the military you aren't a
citizen and so you don't get to
vote or have a stake in the political
process you get treated nice right
nobody like um throws you in prison
camps or stuff like that and they
protect you but you have to serve
um
i mean i will say this i i know a lot of
people who
served precisely as a path to
american citizenship and sometimes they
were the better soldiers you know they
took things seriously
what i want to have a
a political system structured solely on
on you know participation in the
military probably not
um i will say this and this is a bit of
a rant
i think on veterans day the only people
who should have off
our veterans
and all this thanks for your service
[ __ ] people can take that and shove
it and this is what i think a lot of
veterans
and i've talked to a lot of veterans
about this
a lot of them feel that if you want to
actually help a veteran do something to
fix the veterans administration the
hospitals that they go to if you want to
help a veteran
find out what they have you know are
dealing with in terms of ptsd and help
them out or help out their families or
things like that
i think the way that we treat our
veterans here in america is
a lot of window dressing and rah-rah and
parades and then treating them like crap
and and so you know i don't know if it's
the case in other countries but
that's that's a big problem
um chris what is your opinion of the use
of identity politics and the implied
lack of agency of individuals wielded
for political gain how do we manage our
common humanity and political movement i
don't have a problem with identity
politics which is going on on both right
and left as such you know
what i have what i do have a problem
with is when people are just reduced to
um their their identity and and
conflicts right identity politics
doesn't name a single thing it names a
continuum
and it's been going on for hundreds of
years i mean
read about the know-nothing party you
know and uh
think about what native american
originally meant it was used to
designate certain kinds of white
americans that was identity politics
right there in the 1800s
identity politics uh led to the clan
right so it's not just about like
identity politics and in the the way
that we're talking about today and
blaming people largely in ethnic
minorities um so for me that's kind of a
non-starter
um
[Music]
made of clay has a good question here i
know at this point in time republicans
are insane what would be a good
conservative or a good republican
well
a good republican would take account of
the fact of
what's happened to their party
and they would work against that
i would say that that
conservative is itself a slippery term
but there's really little conservative
about so-called conservatives today
they're not conserving
anything except for bad stuff you know
they want to conserve racism they don't
want to actually conserve the
environment which conservatives were all
about in the past you know they want to
hold their hold on to their guns and you
know let's have school shootings that's
the price of freedom that's not a
conservative position uh the
conservative position was from the time
when the nra was actually for gun
control and uh conservatives were for
gun control and being a responsible gun
owner so
you know it's hard to find a real
conservative these days um and you're
certainly not going to find it in the
conservative movement unfortunately
casual philosophy i think good people
tend to ask themselves questions like
are we the baddies because it's the
exact kind of reflectiveness that leads
to goodness in the first place it can
lead to goodness it can also lead to
making excuses it can it can lead to
other kinds of badness right just just
being the the uh enemy or opposed to the
baddies doesn't automatically make you a
goodie especially if you fight fire with
fire right so yeah
um
somebody wrote sadler 2024 i would make
a terrible politician for two reasons
one is there would be so much baggage
you know i mean think about all these
these amas that i've done right somebody
would sample this and they would sound
bite it and there there would be that
would be the end of my uh candidacy
right there but i also man if if you put
me in charge
um
i would be you know
using the national guard against corrupt
cops as i i said we ought to do a long
time ago you know uh the republicans
that are that are doing all these
shenanigans man i'd have them in jail
you know i'd be you know whatever
resources i had we'd we'd be going after
people so you don't want me in charge
i'm a thematic individual and uh
you know
you need people who have
cooler calmer heads i think
um
yeah casual philosophy strong strands of
european conservativism are
pro-environment and anti-capitalists
yeah um
we are the
you know for a long time we had the only
you know
right-wing party that was
anti-environmentalist and denying
climate change unfortunately we've now
bled over into other parties
particularly in the anglo-sphere um
and they've bought into stuff you know
like that but yeah i mean american the
the american right-wing party
is kind of an outlier uh among
right-wing parties in many respects it's
too bad that we're stuck with the the
weirdo you know that way
uh andy says if you want to help
veterans fight the military-industrial
complex house the homeless give people
cheaper free mental health counseling
make education free for everyone yeah
those those are all things that would be
helpful as well there are veterans homes
you know we have one on 35th street here
in milwaukee
the homeless population includes a lot
of veterans and so
doing things like you know for example
street angels here in milwaukee has
committed to opening up a warming center
that will house 25 people 24
7 in in our cold winter those are things
that are concrete and can actually help
people thank you for your service
doesn't help anybody as a matter of fact
it just makes people feel like they've
done something i would say
[Music]
um right uh connor fields points out the
conservatives in australia were pro-gun
control
yeah and and
because they actually learned a lesson
from a terrible shooting right
um here in america we're one of the few
places a lot of people are afraid to
visit america these days not just
because of the failed covid response but
not just because the cops can do
whatever they want you know including
stealing your assets and stuff like that
and get away with it but because of the
prevalence of of handguns and the fact
that we do almost nothing to regulate
them as a society at this point
i i find it
disgusting that my kids have to worry
about somebody coming in and shooting up
the place
you know
um
[Music]
all right let's see what else
we can address because i'm gonna have to
get some lunch pretty soon
uh and then i've got a another thing to
do today
uh
[Music]
something about philosophy sections
um
so here's those here's the thing from
perspective philosophy um what do you
think of mcintyre's point on the rival
forms of rationality that exists between
groups today
you know it's interesting because
mcintyre who who i i know
um he took a stand back in the 2000s
uh saying you you couldn't really vote
for either party
and i haven't i haven't asked him about
this at any
recent time but i i would be i should
check out whether he's revised that at
all um there are there are uh you could
say rival forms of rationality
i think that
you know when we talk about rival forms
of rationality we're setting the bar
high there's other things that are not
even at that point of rationality i
would say much of what's going on
with the republican party doesn't rise
to the level of rationality
um there there might be something like
argument there but much of it is just
cynical flooding flooding the the field
with as much crap as you possibly can
while you plot coos and you know
undermine things as much as possible
um
mario says do you think how do you think
multilateral agreements can be achieved
to face the big crises of the 21st
century
to overcome nationalist egoism and
individual interests of private
corporations i don't know i don't have
an answer for that and i'm i'm kind of
dismayed about you know where we are we
we should be you know america should be
a leader in that and we are just
you know
we're becoming a third you know
essentially a a failed state in many
respects a failed and dangerous state
you know
um
mario says in the moment we get the
feeling everything is breaking more or
less apart and we are at the end of a
long economical cycle and maybe cultural
cycle there's nothing that says that
america
has to continue
um
that we can you know pump as much money
as possible into the defense industry
and you know paying all the all these
other elites off while siphoning wealth
and life out of the majority of the
population
there's nothing that says a culture like
that has to survive you know
i mean i kind of hope we can turn things
around but
maybe we can't you know
um
let's see what else we can
go out on um
[Music]
a lot of stuff about uh conservativism
casual philosophy so they come from a
[ __ ] country i give you permission
to say [ __ ] country now a trumpian
should whole country because trump is
not a good arbiter of that or one that
you would actually describe as as such
um
conor says uh i think i tend to think
one should participate in democracy even
if they are voting for a lesser of two
evils or three
that's what democracy is really about
i mean yeah i mean you have a couple
choices you know light a candle or curse
of darkness right
there's nothing that says that
an action in order to be good must be
one that's actually effective
and
you know
maybe sometimes it's not so much about
voting but about supporting other people
voting or
calling out
the the wrong things that are being done
when they're being done but we can do
something it's just that you know
if it does feel as if most of what we're
doing are not really going to change
things um
secret asian dan how would things be
different and what would your concerns
be if china became the new global
hegemon china is becoming the new global
hegemon whether we like it or not
um and there's some you know some
good points to that and a lot of bad
points to that i mean china is a society
with many many problems as well
it's definitely not anything like you
know where the great mass of people are
being consulted on things and elites run
it you know
even if even if it is nominally
communist
um
but at least they think in terms of 20
years instead of just you know one
election cycle
and
um
i don't know i mean if they can if they
can
steer things in the right direction it's
interesting because you know one of the
people that i did a worlds of
speculative fiction thing on years ago
or not years ago last year was uh lucy
chin
and um
you know he projects a future in which
we speak a combination of english and
chinese right we human beings
um
and who you know that may be where we're
going
so
oh here's a good point from casual
philosophy vote for the lesser of two
evils it creates pressure for par for
parties and politicians to be lesser
evil over the long term yeah i mean if
we can't get them to be actively good
maybe we could get them to not be as bad
so that that is a really
great point
um
yeah that i think that's where we'll
probably end i gotta get some some lunch
soon i'll let you see you know i've been
talking about our wonderful uh state and
city here's a little bit of it
here's our view
of milwaukee
the downtown
and so i'll say thanks to everybody who
asked questions or
provided comments we do these
we do these hopefully every month uh i
think i should be able to
uh commit to that we've got a couple
other things coming up this month i will
also mention too just in case people
haven't seen this in my social media um
a book that i edited stoicism today is
now out
so if you're interested in that sort of
thing you can find it stoicism today
volume 3
on amazon i i will say too that um
my
co-editor did more of the much more work
than than i did
so
uh there's some some nice comments
um
[Music]
about cutting to the chase
so
yeah i actually i also have to get to
grading we have a a bit of a
problem with one of the places where i'm
teaching where all the classes have
closed and my students are kind of in
the lurch so i got to find out what's
going on with it but that's a whole
other story all right i will see all of
you next time around thanks everybody
who joined in
and um stay safe and sane
and uh i'll see you next time